hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
most of you are watching me first time
live on youtube
and there you have it my first ever
chess recruiter against e4
now
when you open and plays e4
if you play sicilian royal affairs
karaoke or the french defense then most
of the club player will know how to
handle those openings
and they will bash out their own theory
against removing
but if you play knight to c6
most of them are thrown to their own
resources
knight to c6 has a big venom because
most of your opponent does not have the
faintest of idea how to play against it
i'm using it from the last one year or
so and i have a tremendous success ratio
with it
today i'm going to share one of my own
secrets with you so sit back relax enjoy
and learn this wonderful and dynamic
opening against e4
now first of all let me brief what i
have covered in this video
i have mainly divided this video in six
different sections
so in the first part we are going to see
what is playing the move d4
after d4 i recommend that you should
certainly hit back in the center with
the move e5
and which has a merit of attacking the
deep one as well in the first part we
are going to see
white is expanding on the queen side
with the move d5
so d5 is not only attacking the knight
but grabbing the more space on the queen
side and somehow this is most critical
reply by the white in the second part we
are going to see white will capture the
e pawn so d cross e5 and after knight
cross e5 you can see i have highlighted
by the arrows white has few good options
and we are going to see
how we are going to deal each of them
in the third part instead of d4
white can try this tricky looking move
which is knight to f3
now knight to f3 has a very cunning idea
that if black plays now e5 then white is
back into some of his familiar
territories
well we are not going to as much
cooperative and here i recommend we will
hit back again with the center
but this time with the move f5 this is
known as colorado gambit now because i
have created the whole video on the
colorado gambit
in the third part i am going to only
look out the lines which can create some
problems to the colorado gambit and i
have gone through
those lines in details
in the fourth part
after d4 and black replies with the move
e5
white can trick black with the move
knight to f3 and this is known as
scotch game here i should certainly
recommend that you capture this pawn and
the main scotch game continues with the
move
knight cross d4
but that's not the only move in the
fifth part i am going to cover white can
play some of the tricky gambits at this
point namely
bishop to c4 which is known as scotch
gambit and the another move is c3 which
is known as godian gambit and we are
going to see how we can diffuse
both of them
in the last part we are going to see
some of the side lines reply by the
white and again there are plenty of them
so the first move is bishop to b5 going
into the rim of the royal lopez
the second move is bishop to c4
again inviting black to going into the
rims of joko piano
the third move is
the move d3 which is an indication of
the king's indian attack
the fourth move is
f4 which is kind of aggressive and
inviting black to go into the rims of
the king's gambit area and the fifth
move is knight to c3 which is again
inviting black to go into the rims of
vienna game and the final sideline is
after d4 e5
white can play a solid looking move
which is c3
which invites black to play knight to f6
and confuse the issue
so this is you pretty much need to know
when you play knight to c6
i know you need to learn many variations
but trust me you just need to go through
it once and you are all set to play this
wonderful opening i'll see you in my
first part
bye